l'hôtel de police de dijon et c'est
cette cellule de garde à vue des
cellules de températures frigorifiques
depuis une rupture de canalisation mi
décembre
fabien est interpellé lors d'une
manifestation de gilet jaune
il est placé en garde à vue une
expérience qui n'oubliera pas de sitôt
c'est totalement indigne tout le monde
peut se retrouver en garde à vue
n'importe quelle raison on a quand même
des droits on peut pas mettre les gens
dans un froid tel que celui-ci moi moi
j'avais ma crainte c'était qu'on
renouvelle ma garde à vue de 24 heures
d'où le fait que que j'avais 10 mai par
fatigue épuisement et j'étais mal
j'avais dit si je reste ce soir je
m'éclate à tête contre les murs je serai
au choix l'hôpital une situation
dénoncée par l'ordre des avocats
il s'insurge contre des conditions
inhumaines et dégradantes portant
atteinte aux droits de la personne c'est
pas adepte dans une cellule à 15 degrés
c'est d'être dans une cellule à 4 degrés
voilà de quoi on parle pendant plusieurs
heures alors que vous êtes son
chaussures que vous n'avez pas de
boisson chaude à disposition que vous
avez une couverture de survie la
personne placée en garde à vue un
certain nombre de droits qui lorsqu'elle
est placée dans ces conditions ne peut
plus qu'elle ne peut plus exercer dans
ces conditions quelle est la valeur que
l'on peut apporter aux déclarations
d'une personne gardée à vue
à mon sens aucune et toutes ces gardes à
vue méritera dette annulée pour jean
claude dunand directeur de la sécurité
publique les conditions d'accueil des
gardés à vue n'ont pas à faire polémique
selon lui des solutions ont été
rapidement mises en place actuellement
nous sommes dans une période où les
gardes à vue sont sauvés avec des
chauffages d'appoint et on a même
renforcer l'isolation par des plaques de
bois dans la tente d'une solution qui
soit plus
performante et pertinente mais
actuellement les gardes à vue sont
chauffés le sont pas aussi bien qu'avant
même chose une solution insuffisante
selon la bâtonnière du barreau de dijon
elle a alerté le procureur de la
république est saisi le contrôleur
général des lieux de privation de
liberté